hello Russian appointed officials in
Carson and Crimea say a Ukrainian
missile has hit a bridge connecting the
regions chungar Bridge has been called
the gate to Crimea which is the
territory annex by Russia in 2014.
crimea's Governor says no casualties
have been reported and he says the
attack was carried out by a Storm Shadow
missile the UK confirmed it had provided
Ukraine's military with those cruise
missiles which have a range of 250
kilometers Al jazeera's Julia
chapovaleva joins us now from Moscow so
what more does the Russian side say
about this attack
so according to reports it was an attack
on several Bridges connecting Crimea and
her son region uh so hours ago Sergey
action of Russian appointed hero Crimea
actually announced as Trigon the achonga
bridge no casualties were reported that
now they're trying to figure out what
type of ammunition was used in the
shelling well Russian appointed head of
the Herson region of Vladimir sander
said that not just one but several
Bridges had been hit he alleged that the
British a long-range Storm Shadow
missiles were used and added that the
road surface was damaged there on the
bridges wow just a bit later on a
correspondent for the Russian State
Aryan novacy news agency actually
confirmed the strike on the bridge in
that changa had been carried out by the
Storm Shadow missiles we understand that
the traffic between the Harrison region
and the Crimean Peninsula is now carried
out along a backup route the authorities
promised that the traffic on the damaged
breaches would be restored very soon so
basically that's the latest we're here
we're here now here yeah and how
significant is the targeted area from a
military point of view Julia
well obviously it's a vitally important
area from the Strategic point of view
it's the so-called land Corridor to
Crimea according to sources the road
that runs through a chonga is the
shortest route from Crimea to the
mainland city of militopo controlled by
Russia and then it goes further to the
southern front with the counteroffensive
of the Armed Forces of Ukraine is
underway now at the moment Russia
controls a large part of the area but
Ukraine obviously realizes the Strategic
importance of the area therefore we can
presume that more military Maneuvers can
be expected in that direction in the
near future thank you so much reporting
from Moscow